get out of here dude I'm sorry I'm
nasally guys you guys I'm really nasally
why I got stuffed up because dude I'm
[ __ ] nasally by I went to the doctor
the other day and I go like this what is
it and he's like dude sometimes you're
just [ __ ] too sick with it that's not
what the doctors I was like I'm sorry
and he was like yeah he looked at me up
from his glasses and goes like this
there's really nothing I could prescribe
you I said but you're the doctor he said
I know but there's nothing we can do
you're just too sick with it he said
you're too sick with it and I'm like
that's why I'm nasally and he says
that's my best guess too sick with it so
WI DD T or D I don't know I don't even
know but he just goes you're sick with
it man you are sick with it and then I
go out and I go to pay and I was like
what do I owe and they were like you
know what we don't want to charge you we
love your work but you're come on I know
I know I said I'll tell come on please
right I know I was in your shoes right
here I was like please let me pay
something you know at least two three
grand I don't know how much it cost but
they were like whatever doesn't make a
but but she was like she was like yeah
you're sick with it and I was like ah
it's all good she's like I knew somebody
who was sick with it once I was like who
and she said a Gregory Peck I was like
Jesus that was a long time ago but
apparently you know he was very famous
for your time period but that's there's
no like The Grapes of Wrath which was
big right oh and Brian was 40 all right
but but congratulatory is very funny Sam
congratulatory because my podcast
congratulations is just skyrocketing in
the charts man you've been talking about
yourself the whole time no need to start
talking about other things besides
yourself not people you know what's
funny I'm not talking about myself but I
think I I swear to god there was a
second a few months ago I started
thinking of I started thinking that my
name was what the [ __ ] it's him you're
insufferable no no this is other people
I know what's going on dude I've been
around you yeah you get recognized okay
but don't act like you're not justin
beep no no that's what I say to them I'm
like guys it's not Justin Bieber and
they go like what the [ __ ] it's I
thought my name
for us for a second I sorta got it now
my name was what the [ __ ] there he is no
no and I was like what my name is Chris
yeah and they're like yeah we know yeah
and you know I've seen a lot of pictures
of you sometimes that on the internet
when you're young mmm when you didn't
have a beard and when you had short hair
mm-hmm and it was interesting because
like that's the guy with the lunch pail
right
what well wait what well some people go
through a transition and what they do is
they go there's the guy you shove in the
corner okay I'm your lunch whatever it
is right or or let's just shove them
around or or you know what that's what
they do right yeah no and then then go
don't get then you get mad in the mirror
and you I'm gonna change that's true and
then you go any of your dad's like let's
get them a stylist and then you do your
bad toupee just a thousand ten thousand
whenever and then he got the Chagos grow
your hair long grow scruff and then
reinvent yourself because your name used
to be Dennis now it's Chris is that true
no that's not true my new who's never
Dennis it could have been back then
right all right no it was not it
couldn't have been my name is Chris and
only Chris wait a minute if it would
have made a deaf and also people [ __ ]
if anything my name is what the [ __ ]
it's him and that's what I'm saying now
when you're at your holiday what you
post video soon as if you're you and
you're your home your dad can barely
barely take you and your brother like I
said the most ridiculous comments true
we do we have ridiculous conversations
but you know what
he made us so it's his fault I know it's
not you guys are close though yeah we
were very close cuz mom good how's that
good how's your brother who looks up to
me no that's not actually he's skinny I
could beat his ass okay dude okay but
why are you saying when I see him I go
punch you in the chest once you'd quit
but why would you say that to him but
why would you say that I just want him
to know that I can kick his ass all
right dude yeah I like I can kick his
ass and by the way if he's walking
around with his girl I'll take her if I
want bro okay you don't know who's a
that I wouldn't know well I got it I got
to man I go
hey scram alright that's some 1960s
[ __ ] and I know what you say scram
to my brother one time no no no that's
disrespectful
grando and then and then you you go nah
bro yeah you know Brian don't you try to
you you try to
peacock up and die bro I go what know
what I'm too lazy for you to deal with
bro I'm shoe like you for you to deal
with you want you want to stab huh you
want to that brought me that's
absolutely not how it will go down you
want these [ __ ] spaghetti arms
wrapped around your [ __ ] neck dude
you in the mood for some dying in huh
you in the mood for some [ __ ] dalian
food that you say when you [ __ ] up I got
like that I look at people dead [ __ ]
square in the eye and I say hey dude
are you hungry cuz I got some dyin food
for you four years and then I [ __ ]
whip around they don't even know they're
like we're to go and I'm behind them
just strangling the [ __ ] out of really
strangle I don't even choke I strike
okay take it easy the last time you
thought you were in a fight oh god dude
so many times we have you and your
brother ever come to fisticuffs only one
time really yeah how old were you
young college to him you did yeah cuz he
was choking me or he punched me or
something I don't remember younger
brother - yeah and you you beat him up
he was punching me or something then I
let him have it but I was bigger and
older so now dude don't be it was
probably about some cool [ __ ] like money
or checks right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]